Now.
So let's take a look at the stories and
let's take a look at the leading
figures.
So we know,
for example,
that the figure of Satan and
Christianity is associated with a number
of strange forms,
right?
The first association we know of is that
he's associated with the,
with the dragon and in the garden of
Eden,
right?
So there's a,
and so that there's a profound
ambivalence and Christianity about the
meaning of the opening act of genesis.
Because on the one hand you have,
when Adam and eve are still profoundly
unconscious,
they don't suffer,
but they're profoundly unconscious,
right?
They're not self conscious,
they're not aware of themselves.
So in many ways there's still animals.
So there's a gnostic line of
speculation.
The gnostics were a Christian sect that
believed that a redemption could at
least partly be attained by
understanding rather than just faith.
The gnostics believed that the,
the serpent that tempted Adam and eve
towards self consciousness was a more
developed aspect of God than the God
that had created Adam and Eve to begin
with.
Because the unconsciousness that
characterized Adam and eve was to
underdeveloped to be perfect.
And so they had to be tempted forward
into a more fully developed
consciousness.
And so although classical Christianity
associated the serpent in the tree with
Lucifer,
who's the bringer of light,
who Satan,
the gnostic thread of reasoning said,
well,
wait a minute.
It's not that simple because yeah,
selfconsciousness makes you aware of
death and vulnerability and,
and knocks you out into the profane
world.
But there's an aspect of it,
the kind of looks like enlightenment.
And you know this already in your own
lives because often when you believe
something and you're unconsciously
convinced of the adequacy of that model,
and then you find that it's not
sufficient,
right?
And so you crumble in disappointment,
you put your trust in someone and you
find out,
say they're not worthy of that trust.
And that,
that the evidence that enlightens you
breaks that frame of reference and makes
you collapse.
You think that's a terrible thing.
You can't help but feel that as a real
betrayal and as an act even of evil.
But then a year later,
two years later,
you might look back and think,
God,
you know,
I really needed that.
I really needed that lesson because as a
consequence of learning that I'm much
more mature and much more likely to
establish stable relationships.
And so it's easy to see that from one
perspective,
something can be terrible and then from
another,
it might not be terrible at all.
And even in classic Christianity,
you get this strange ambivalence about
the events in genesis that runs
something like this.
Well,
yes,
it was an act of the,
of the most evil spirit,
the spirit of enlightenment,
the spirit of rationality,
or the bringer of light,
Lucifer to knock Adam and eve out of
their transcendental unconsciousness and
to start history,
it was an evil act,
but on the other hand,
it was also the precondition for the
later emergence of Christ.
And as far as the Christians are
concerned,
that's the greatest event in history.
So without this initial opening act,
right,
this tragic opening act,
there'd be no reason for the whole
redemptive story and therefore
considered from the perspective of the
total story.
The opening tragedy cannot purely be
considered evil.
Very,
very complicated line of reasoning.
Now,
the other thing you see here,
and I think this relates back to our
initial map is,
and this also helps you understand the
way people think.
Now I said already that it's real easy
to confuse tragedy and evil,
right?
Okay.
So what that means is that it's real
easy to confuse the negative aspect of
the unknown with evil and likewise it's
very easy to confuse the negative aspect
of culture with evil,
your own culture,
the tear radical aspect of it or the
culture of other people.
So it's very easy for,
for example,
for us to demonize the foreigner and
that's basically because there's a part
of our mind that presumes that all
things that strike us negatively,
all things that produce negative emotion
on our part,
like fear are the same thing.
So there's a a blurry category of evil
that's all terrible natural things,
all terrible social things.
And then whatever nastiness the
individual can generate among
themselves,
it's much more useful to draw a clear
distinction between these different
categories because that clarity of
thought can help you,
can help you focus in most specifically
on those things that the individual is
responsible for in terms of turning the
world to waste.
So Milton says this figure of Satan,
Lucifer,
the,
the light bringer always associated with
rationality.
Milton presents him as a remarkable
creature,
right?
He's the head highest angel in God's
heavenly hierarchy.
He's Christ elder brother in,
uh,
in a similar mythological vein.
He's the most powerful angel that ever
lived.
So at least in the opening stages of
this act,
Satan is presented as something
absolutely remarkable.
Now,
the problem is here,
his very remarkable illness starts to
work against him.
And what happens is that as he grows in
power and strength in this heavenly
hierarchy starts to become convinced
that the omniscient himself,
whatever,
that transcendent figure is,
is unnecessary.
So the idea is that whatever Satan
represents decides because of his own
pride,
his own belief in his own sufficiency,
that the transcendent can be eradicated
from consideration the way Milton
presents.
That is as a revolution in heaven,
fundamentally.
So imagine that the story is something
like this.
Well,
George Kelley,
way back in like 1955 noted that what
human beings like more than anything
else really when you get right down to
it is to be right.
Why?
Well,
it's a pain to be wrong,
right?
Because if you're wrong,
then the little structure that you're
using to conjure up the world has to
dissolve and then you have to do a lot
of really aggravating work,
exploratory work and creative work to
put it back together.
And during the time,
before you put it back together,
then you're flooded with negative
motivational states,
right?
You don't know which way is up,
metaphorically speaking.
So we don't like to be,
we don't like not to be.
Right.
And,
and so what does that mean?
Well,
psychologists know that people have a
very strong confirmatory bias,
which basically means that if you bring
a frame of reference to bear on the
world,
the probability is very high,
that you will look for confirming
evidence and you will discount
disconfirming evidence.
Now the other thing that is
characteristic of great figures of evil,
like Satan is their tendency to lie,
right?
So Satan is prince of the lie.
Now what does that mean exactly?
Yeah.
So Tsl Eliot wrote this poem called the
cocktail hour.
He talks about this woman goes in for
psychiatric treatment.
The woman says to the psychiatrist,
I'm telling Ya,
I really,
really hope there's something wrong with
me because I'm having a miserable time
of it.
And as far as I can tell,
there's only two options here.
Either I'm okay and I'm having a
miserable time because the world is
terrible,
in which case there's nothing I can do
about it.
Or there's something wrong with me at
some level of analysis that I don't
really comprehend.
And although that's a painful option,
I'm really hoping it's true because if
there's something wrong with me,
possibly I can fix it and if there's
something wrong with the structure,
the world,
well,
what's there to do about that?
Okay.
Often what you see in psychotherapy is a
battle between those two perspectives
going on in the minds of the client that
the client is in a situation where
they're repetitively facing tragedy,
they have a specific viewpoint about the
world,
like their viewpoint might be,
well,
when it comes right down to it,
you really can't trust other people and
they have all sorts of reasons for
believing that they were abused as
children or they've had a bad
developmental history,
a number of relationships that haven't
gone well.
They have all the facts at their
disposal to justify that particular
perspective,
but the truth of the matter is is that
as long as they hold on to that belief
and won't let it go and and no wonder
they won't,
they're going to continue to suffer.
And part of what you're always doing to
someone in therapy saying,
you know,
yeah,
you got a pretty coherent view of the
world and all that,
and I can understand why you'd like to
cram the whole world into that coherent
perspective.
But the truth of the matter is,
as long as you hold onto that and won't
sacrifice it,
right,
we'll go through this terrible period of
disillusion.
It's always going to produce the same
tragic consequences.
So as long as you hold onto your belief
rigidly,
everything around you is going to go
from bad to worse.